hey what is up guys mkbhd here and these
are the jaybird x2s they are these
bluetooth earbuds they're the sequel
actually to the jaybird bluebuds x that
i liked so much last year so this is the
review of them it should be pretty easy
so the originals of these guys the
jaybird bluebuds x were some of my
favorite headphones like ever i didn't
even use earbuds that much but i would
pretty much never leave the house
without these they're bluetooth earbuds
that last like forever on battery they
have great sound they happen to be under
200 bucks so i included them on my top
five headphones under 200 list uh and a
lot of people have loved them ever since
now here's the thing these came out like
three years ago so all the technology
from the inside and out has improved in
the last three years so the jaybird x2s
aren't really like a design overhaul or
anything like that they're more of a
refresh of remaking the same product
with new technology for 2015. so here's
what's new with the jaybird x2 that
rhymed okay first of all they're not
blue buds anymore there's no blue buds
anywhere on the box actually they're
just the x2s now and they do come in a
few colors so the originals were just
black or white the x2s come in a variety
of colors my personal favorite of course
being the red and black which is called
fire this is everything that comes in
the box the headphones the case three
different size rubber ear tips and now
new three different size foam ear tips
so the soft foam these actually used to
be an optional paid accessory so it's
nice that they actually include these
for free as a part of the package now
you also get the ear fins that help them
stay in your ears and a tiny usb 2.0
cable all you really need to do is get
your bluetooth device to play music from
and you're good to go and you can pair
with up to eight devices to this just
one pair of headphones the biggest
improvement or actually i think the
biggest change mechanically speaking is
actually the carrying case so the
original models carrying case was this
sort of a hard clam shell design
definitely protective but super annoying
to open the new case is a hard shell on
the bottom but then more of a flexible
soft rubber on the side so you can just
pop off the top put your headphones or
accessories in there and then when you
want to close it you just pop the top
right back on when you're done it's a
lot easier for me than that clamshell
and the other big mechanical improvement
for the jaybird x2s is the improved ear
fins which are a bit more comfortable a
little bit softer to help these things
stay more securely in your ear when
moving or running you technically don't
have to use the fins but they help the
earbuds stay more firmly in my ear for
keeping the seal and keeping the dope
sound and speaking of dope sound yes
these do still sound awesome
this is again where new technology comes
into play you can fit better drivers
into a smaller place you can work on the
sound profile of such a small pair of
headphones the bluetooth connection is
more reliable etc and they still have
this really rich uh warm punchy sound
like the last version super fun to
listen to especially for sports and
stuff they charge fully in about two
hours and they still have that really
long eight hour battery life and that
might not sound like an all-day thing
but if you only listen to music for two
hours every single day that's going to
last you almost a week and just the
overall fit and finish is better here
there's improved water resistance it
feels like the connection with the cable
of the earbuds is more solid and the
soft touch finish is way better looking
and feeling in the hand than the glossy
casing of last year so there's pretty
much nothing i don't like about this
refresh even if you've never used
bluetooth headphones at all before these
would be a great first pair considering
they're super easy to use and pair and
get started with and then they're really
durable so if you do drop them or you
play a rough sport or have a long
practice or get them wet they will
survive so when it comes down to it
there are no better wireless earbuds for
the price and i've tried a lot of them
uh i just can't get past recommending
these now here's the bonus the originals
the jaybird bluebugs x which are still
pretty good uh now they dropped in price
so it's like a new smartphone coming out
the older version drops in price a lot
i'll leave the link right below if you
want to check out the original jaybird
bluebuds x and get them for a steal i
think they're now like way under 150
bucks now so that's pretty dope and i'll
also be giving away a second pair of the
jaybird x2s so if you want to check out
a pair of those uh stay tuned on twitter
i'll leave my twitter link below some
twitter giveaway action will be
happening that's basically it if you
enjoy this video feel free to leave it a
thumbs up thank you for watching and
i'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace